hallo Murat hallo klickst du meine Frage
an dich du hast früher Polizist und wie
kommt man auf die Idee in so einem
ernsten Beruf
Comedian zu werden ja
hallo Denny also zum einen so ernst ist
der Beruf bei der Polizei gar nicht von
vielen wird das so empfunden dass sie
sagen okay alle Polizisten sind bloß so
ernste Typen ähm man erlebt meiner liebt
viele Dinge natürlich auch vieles viel
tragisches aber eben auch sehr lustige
und skurrile Geschichten und wenn man da
eine entsprechende Wahrnehmung hat und
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen rundumor
den übrigens schon auch einige
Polizisten haben ja
dann
kann man eben die Dinge so wie ich sehe
halt als Comedian jetzt verwende eben
auch güntauglich
an die an den Mann und die Frau bringen
so ist das passiert ich habe Dinge
erzählt die ich erlebt habe Geschichten
die das Leben schrieb auf eine
offensichtliche sehr lustige Art und
Weise und so bin ich dazu gekommen vom
lustigen Polizisten zum hoffentlich auch
lustigen Comedian zu werden